thank you Michael and thanks everyone
for coming to my talk
um my name is Taco at Taco Wang I'm here
uh presenting this talk title designing
human centered AI systems for Human air
collaboration
a very quick background about myself I'm
currently working at IBM research
business scholar at Stanford so my
office is a case126 if you want to talk
to me after the talk I'll be here at
least until the end of the year I'm also
Adam professor at the Northeastern
University so where I teach some classes
there
um I have been studying and working in
China France and the US so if you have
interest in studying abroad wondering
all those different cultures of work and
the study also I can share some
anecdotal stories there my recent
interest now falls into the intersection
between HCI Ai and group collaboration
so a study and built a human-centered AI
systems but I'm also from IBM research
many people may wonder if my research
actually succeeds my colleagues research
actually you know play a impact why how
could IBM's product failed miserably in
the real world for example the IBM was
in healthcare system uh what I can tell
you uh is that I I'm not uh involved in
the IBM Western health research team but
in my own research work where I studied
this uh AI supported clinical decision
making systems I do observe some common
patterns and uh reasons of failure that
I can share with you in this talk
in this particular case where you know
you have a typical EHR system to the
left and then you have a
AI based clinical decision support
system cdss system to the right has a
pop-up and then the designer followed
all those uh human-centered design
guidelines to make sure that uh at the
accuracy is good for example the uh the
54 accuracy and also uh there are
particular design considerations to
support the Expendable AI for example
these are the highlighted keywords uh
using attention bases so that doctors
can better understand why this
particular option is being suggested
but uh still
um
these systems fail uh fail I mean that
you know after deployment after you know
millions of dollars investment and then
deploying the real world clinics uh
doctors stopped using them after a
couple monthses uh why does my
fundamental uh motivation uh research
motivation right why do some AI systems
work and some don't in the real world
um let's look at that a look back at the
history so this is a nice chart
depicting uh the ups and the Downs of
the AI research AI investment in the
history this is from Johnson gluten from
Microsoft research so we are observing
these uh trends that IBM was in health
failed in
2019 but it's not the first time in the
history uh in the 80s in the in the 80s
there
in the 80s there are these similar
efforts being tried in the UK for
example there's a medical research
Council I had this brilliant idea of
developing algorithms to automatically
scan uh the medical images but the test
system also failed uh principally we
don't really use it
and
the healthcare context is not the only
like you know scenario or the use case
where investors and researchers have
been extensively invested and failed in
many other use cases for example uh in
this chatbot or intelligent agent
scenario
Microsoft Office clippy which was you
know a very famous or in famous kind of
example in the in the previous wave of
this AI summer but now we have a chatbot
it only takes one year to make people
sentiment from oh it's the year of
chatbot in 2017. then becomes a why chat
box fail in 2018.
for the younger audience maybe the MS
clippy Microsoft clip maybe before your
age so this is a Microsoft clippy uh
inside the office world and then
um Ada tells you well it's kind of like
using this icon view to tell you I have
to ask how many of you know of clippy or
new of Clippy
perfect wow just about to the next slide
so we should still all remember uh
Microsoft Tay right so this is uh quite
a disaster because it takes only you
know less than 24 hours to turn a social
chichat bot uh deployed on Twitter to
become a pro Nazi anti-social uh agent
right so Microsoft put it down
so come back to the you know AI for
healthcare use case why
um these decisions are failing uh there
are various reasons but I think one main
reason that I'm really interesting is
that uh
um is conveyed in this actual in this
picture so designers and engineers and
researchers sometimes we try to build
these AI models to replace human doctors
uh maybe that was not the intention of
these researchers and designers but
that's the perception we pass on to the
actual Target user and once they
perceive it in such a way it's a
competitor inside of a collaborator then
people stop using it
um we actually heard this kind of
feedback from our you know contextual
inquiries right so doctors were
complaining about you know why it's not
uh helpful why is trying to take their
own job but instead of you know
providing support that they actually
need so they suggest that you know can
you provide an Expendable trustworthy
and Cooperative aicidescent system for
this future human AI collaboration
now I believe we have a potential answer
to answer this question
um which is human AI collaboration
I Define or corn this concept as you
know the the goal and the design process
should be you know trying to design this
human-centered AI systems to be a
collaborator instead of competitor so
that the human AI teams can deliver
their uh outcome at a higher quality or
you know in a faster space and also you
know that should be integrated into the
existing human workflow so
um that's uh the main topic of this uh
talk
now let's look at you know uh if
everyone follows my thought uh human AI
collaboration is great but why we don't
have it uh now right
so let's look at the human right so the
human researchers and designers who are
actually working on this topic this
human-centered AI topic first we have a
group of researchers primarily focusing
on the merchant learning uh state of art
performance and that is trying to design
better models uh you know more powerful
models and also the new model
architecture that you can present
results with a more Expendable
interpretable or Fair uh prediction
there's another group of researchers
mostly us right user study researchers
HCA researchers a social scientists
focusing mostly on the design guidelines
and the new UI features a new
interaction experience for uh the AI
system and also sometimes we study the
trustworthy issue the societal impact
issue after the system being deployed
into the real world
the real problem is these two group of
researchers don't really talk to each
other we published a totally different
venues we don't follow the research work
from this uh different venues right and
uh that's why you know in order to
deliver a bill to these AI systems to
fully deliver the human collaboration
promise we need to close the loop
uh my work uh no fits into that Gap and
trying to close this loop as I conduct a
user-centered design research method to
the left
to my right yes so and then um from
understanding how a user uh Works in
their real day life and what they need
we can then uh digest this
understandings and knowledges as new
data sets or new tasks or even new model
designs so that these can be translated
into the language of the machine
Learning Community can understand then
we can build a state of art models to
actually solve those tasks or utilizing
those domain knowledge after that once
we have the model it's still not to the
end right our goal is to actually
support humans so we need to have a good
system design and UI design so that we
can wrap those machine models into a
human Center AI system so that that
system can serve actually as the
interface between the human intelligence
and the Machine intelligence
in this talk I would like to highlight
uh three lines of my work AI for uh
Healthcare biomedical domain secondly AI
for uh education and the last one is AF
or data science
through these three small case studies I
want to illustrate also these three
different research approaches the first
one is you know how to apply
user-centered design research methods
for studying and designing these AI
systems secondly how can I I try to I
want to illustrate a full cycle of this
closing the loop research methodology
how you can collaborate with different
experts from different communities and
then deliver this this whole vision of
the loop third one from this uh studying
how human data scientists work together
we want to learn from human human
collaboration and then we can get this
design for human AI collaboration
foreign
so let's start to look at the first case
study so the first one um we adopted
this uh user-centered design research
method to identify user needs for an
online Health Community so this
community is particularly designed for
pregnant women then we can build and
deploy a human Loop AI system to provide
timely social support to the people's
emotional needs
user Center design I'm sure like most of
people in this audience already know
that is a corned by the Norman back in
1970s it emphasizes this iterative
design process so that you know we we
can gather user feedback early and make
sure that our design aligns with the
user needs and also do it iteratively
so in my study and we start with this
user-centered design method by looking
into the actual you know context of the
study site that we are focusing on
um this is a very typical cscw type of
work that we uh run we collected the
posts and responses from this online
community and then we conducted a
qualitative coding to try to understand
why are people using this online
community and what are the responses
from there we categorize them into uh
four different categories but uh the
these three are the most prominent ones
if we uh when we take a further look at
the responses then for the first one
this emotional support seeking and the
emotional sharing type of uh posts and
the third one the sharing daily live
posts the responses are very similar uh
because it's just you know people
provide some emotional or cheat head
caloric responses
the second step of user-centered designs
to identify user needs so what would be
the user needs in this particular use
user in this particular Health Community
so we found that the medium response
time for a post is roughly 10 minutes
um it's okay for a general online
committee but for these pregnant women
this special User Group they have very
high you know stress level and you know
we got a lot of complaints that you know
they they need a more timely response
then our research team decided uh why
don't we try to build a aib solution to
help with this timely response
user needs for the emotional support
seeking scenario
so from that uh
design a guideline design inside we
decided to build this a chat about for
social uh support or cast
so this system has a human in the loop
um here architecture
um it has five modules right so the
first module is responsible for
identifying those posts that do not have
a timely support then for those were
called overlooked posts the second
module uh use a deep learning classifier
cleaner classifier to be able to
distinguish whether those posts have
emotional support or informational
support due to various
FDA regulation we cannot provide these
informational support like they really
need to seek uh advice from doctors
right and then in the third module it's
just uh for our infield uh experiment
setup which I'll come back later
the fourth module is a neural network
based response generation module we
collect two years of data from this uh
online community and then change the
model to learn how other human committee
members respond to these posts
just give you a very quick qualitative
view of how these original posts look
like what's the training data that human
response which is to the ground choose
the training data and then our as a
performance as you can see for example
you know what especially the third one
right they can even generate this Emoji
only responses
um I right I I need to emphasize that
this work was done in 2019 2020 so there
were no like you know a lot of funding
model yet so this worker was a primarily
using a nmt a natural uh neural machine
translator model back then
uh to make sure that our AI want to you
know post any inappropriate messages
back to the community and how to repeat
the Microsoft taste uh failure so with
the available of this human in the loop
verification and refinement module after
each response is generated a human
moderator can look at the response
content so in this sense the whole you
know human Loop
AI architecture this entire caste system
is actually just supported that the
human content moderator to scale up her
uh his or her work
after we developed this entire system we
decided to deploy it back to the Target
community so this is a seven day field
experiment uh this is the last step of
user Center design research Loop where
you need to evaluate the solution
against the target user back into the
community right during these seven days
there are 3400 roughly uh posts that are
looking for emotional support but do not
have a timely response amount is a 3400
poster we randomly split into two groups
for the control group we do nothing uh
just you know keep monitoring what other
human beings they come here and they
respond for the experiment group we have
our AI system to interact uh I just want
to share uh lyrically two result
highlights so the first series uh there
is a highlight is cast can indeed
support individual email support Seekers
um emotional uh balance score to become
more uh positive so uh looking at this
chart to the left that's our experiment
group to the right this is the human
Response Group that the control group
where you can see the uh we we
calculated this uh emotional balance
score for the original uh post and then
there are 49 are negative after our AI
intervention in the uh is still the same
poster but coming back to responds to
the AI response right so the negative
emotion
shrink significantly and also the
positive uh emotion like no twist sorry
not response increase we observe the
similar Trend in the human Response
Group which means it doesn't matter
whether you have ai or human response to
this uh posters as some ways are
interacting with them their you know
emotions become less negative
we also have a surprising finding so
this is a second Finance so this caste
system is dispatch it was designed to
support this individual uh emotions oh
sorry question
um I was wondering whether you could
explain the drop in positive emotional
valence in the human response setting
because it feels that's like a pretty
big drop yes
um and then yeah I was just curious like
why that was the case
um whether it seems to suggest that
maybe human responses aren't
you know as reliable
um or maybe they would not provide like
positive evidence data for an AI to be
trained on so like that might also Mark
as
um data that you know we should be a
little bit careful on but before we
train language models on them yeah so
thank you so much the the question is
why in the human Response Group that uh
positive emotional ones actually uh
shrink a little bit right so
um we have a that's a very good
observation and that we have a theory uh
in our paper discussion section we feel
like you know it's not just about the
content so uh what is being written in
that response it's also related to time
right so how quick that response is
being posted back to that uh
thread of discussion maybe it's because
I know uh they they were very high the
original poster were very happy to share
baby's photo or or some you know a very
interesting like Live Events and then no
one replied to that uh poster Within
a couple days right and then after a
while and then some human Community
member may come in and then say Oh
there's a lovely baby right but by that
time maybe the the you know posters uh
emotion have already you know turn to
neutral right so it's not turned to
negative that is turned to neutral that
that's our Theory but we haven't tested
it yet
no yeah that's that's also a very uh
good uh question so uh the the question
is you know does the identity of the AI
or the bot are being uh disclosed to the
participants so the answer is no because
we uh tourism first um we from
literature we know that if you disclose
the thoughts identity it will
significantly reduce humans perception
and the Trust In no matter what the
quality was other kind of things in this
case in this study that wasn't our uh
focus of the study so we want to make
sure that we we can control that
variable secondly we
we position our paper or our work as a
AI system like humans and AI system to
support that human content moderator so
during this seven day deployment we
actually have a research assistant
student right monitoring the entire
system 11 hours per day right and then
while that system was uh online
generating those to make sure that every
single response generated by the system
actually is being verified by the
student because
so I can also give you the a little bit
more detail I we think because of the
training data have been already like
censored or filtered uh from the past
two years by the human content
moderation on the community so the the
models generator response there's no uh
like you know arbitrary or inappropriate
response at all so our uh research and
didn't do any intervention uh in this
case
so
I'm trying to think about whether this
is sustainable in the long term because
if you're focused on emotional support
and emotional support is essentially
keyed on the fact that it's costly to
deliver you know if I spend time with
someone to help them through a tough
moment it's it's you know partially that
I've spent time with them you know this
this is sort of like Donna's entire
point of like like social like honest
signals and social signaling or signals
in Social super Nets and all this it's
like essentially saying that the
emotional support works because someone
spent time to do it yes and because this
is basically free I'm worried that over
time it'll turn into you know I call I
call customers some support and they say
your call is important to us you know
please hold and it's it it's basically
if anything negative because it's
um it's like acting as if this is a
social interaction when it just got
auto-generated for free so I'm wondering
what happens as as this kind of thing
goes further
uh yes I think that's a very valid
concern uh but from this seven day field
day deployment that we couldn't observe
that but what do we know in many of
today's online communities right so like
uh
I wouldn't name them but in many of
those online communities this
architecture uh is actually being used
uh in practice despite whether they
disclose it or not so they have a small
team of human content moderators look at
it this uh whether it's for emotional
support purpose or for you know his
speech or or misinformation filtering
purpose is all like that and after a
while after a long deployment whether
you know it will have some uh like
effects or fading out then that's
something that I think you know we have
to be able to access the actual data log
data from this user community
yeah
okay so uh again back oh sorry back to
uh the second final highlight in this
particular study is that you know
despite we designed the systems for this
individual user right uh but the actual
uh it actually has some positive uh
impact on the entire community so look
at this two plots right the uh blue line
is the uh experimental group the orange
line is the uh you know human group
right so without any intervention our AI
intervention only only internet once
which is that a red circle and then all
the you know blue circle are all other
human community members coming in so
this plot is plotting the interval time
uh between two uh following like
responses what is telling us is that you
know after our as uh like timely
response the entire Community are
becoming more active uh become more
engaging uh under those uh threats right
so the second tweet a second response to
the first uh third response to the
second one are all much shorter right so
coming uh much quicker in comparison to
the uh the original kind of control
group
which is also you know telling us that
you know this may be an interesting uh
research direction for the future that
you have ai to uh engage with the
community or more than one user question
yes for the human response experiment
um how were the
human like writers sort of incentivize
like because you mentioned that for the
AI response there was a student that was
on 24 almost like you know very was very
active
um for moderating uh the content that
was being generated but is was also a
similar case for in the human setting
um because otherwise like
um this time interval is sort of
um you know the reason why this is
discrepancy could just be that like oh
if we just hire you know humans that are
always on all the time then you know we
will see a smaller interval then the
difference would be like content that's
generated between the Hue the AI versus
human oh that's that's a very fair uh
you know uh question right so I want to
again like it really to read our student
despite you know uh she's like you know
11 hours like you know uh on right is is
only that red thought so that the
beginning like the first response to
that post all the others so our
basically reinter and once for one post
and then uh leave that uh post forever
right we just monitor what others are
doing so uh even if you know so that's
why you see that the difference between
that uh First Response and the original
original post right but then uh what we
are observing is this uh this uh uh much
uh shorter timing interval in all the
following uh human to human responses uh
that's the the difference that we are
observing and that we are excited about
it that that shows that AI come in once
and then I left but all the other human
these are all the same like online
community members right they come into
this uh posts like more uh
often a little more timely and not the
other ones
I'm trying to like figure out what it
feels like the control is not like I
guess like the maybe the experiment that
I'm like thinking in my mind is like
instead of having a student moderate the
content like could you conduct the
experiment where or have you conducted
the experiment where the AI generates a
response and the community members that
moderate before
publishing because in the in the Orange
Line you're relying on community members
being active and also generating and
then publishing right in the blue line
it's the AI generates but then you have
a student that is always moderating it's
only the first one the first one and
then all these uh following four
thoughts like the second response third
response if it's a response are all the
committee members are also creating and
generating and the posting okay yeah
yeah
thank you
I probably should uh be uh quicker so
there are some other you know uh papers
that we got in this AF or Healthcare and
medical domain um if you're interested
you can chat with me uh so but in in
this particular study I was trying to
say like you know users and design as a
a very last thing and a promise in
research method is still very valid when
we try to design build a successful AI
systems
to support this human AI collaborating
in the real world the second work is uh
building a
building a air system to support the
storybook reading experience for parent
case um interaction
um it's getting uh trying to I I'm
showing a full cycle of closing Loop
where you need an interdisciplinary
research team to collaborate and then
translating the knowledge between the
HSI community and the ml Community but
the first let's take a look look at a
video
in the automated bot reading mode where
the parent is absent story buddy allows
the parent to select a book preview the
generated questions select the ones to
use and customize the bot child
interaction in advance
after the parent configuration is
finished story buddy is able to read the
book Three Bears
facilitate interactive question
answering through a conversational bot
without the parents intervention
okay so this is the story buddy uh
assistant demo we presented at Kai early
this year but why we started uh this
project right so let's uh take a step
back and look at the beginning of this
entire project so we started by you know
asking this a very simple question uh
during the covet our parents are at home
uh kids are bonded at home right you
know parents need to work and also cook
right so how can AI help this apparent
uh children uh storybook reading
experience
uh within that context we designed this
uh experiment it's a two by two Factor
uh design one factor is that we have
human adults to read the storybook the
other uh uh vertices that we have ai
agent to read the storybook the other
factor is that during the historical
reading experience do you have
interactive dialogue uh basically
question and answer or not right or we
recruited 120 case uh age between three
to six and then the AIA script to use
the same question site and the book as
with the human adult
very quick uh video
[Music]
that is correct
okay question why do you think the bear
stopped at this island to look for a
Blue Shield
[Music]
good job yes you're right what did the
Bears make okay so that was is the you
know the user study uh setting and we
collect the many measurements but if we
only look at one particular measurement
which is the historical reading
comprehension outcome right uh the
result is showing us this uh that with
humor or with uh uh this uh AI agent to
deliver that experience it's not that
different for this three to six years
old kit but whether you have a
interactive conversation or not during
that Starbucks reading experience is a
significant uh uh it's using the battery
if you have that you know interaction
uh this gives us you know promising kind
of research Direction but there are two
technical challenges in order to scale
it up first we need to a Content
curation team a domain experts teachers
right that they understand the book and
they understand the you know pedagogical
principles they can translate that
aesthetic book narrative into such a
dialogue flow data structure so that it
can you know support a chatbot then you
need a engineering team to actually
develop write the code and develop such
a chatbot for Google home or Amazon
Alexa or or mobile app so these two
steps so far are primary menu effort
we have a proposal that we propose you
know that our goal is very simple right
to translate this uh static uh storybook
narrative like Snow White into a in-text
experience right but when we look into
that uh uh effort right so uh it's it's
actually more complicated than we
thought first we need a data set again
domain data set because until today the
uh the
for young kids uh reading material there
hasn't been a data set being collected
for this educational purpose then we
need new models we need a model that can
generate this kind of question answers
uh with some educational uh value in it
and then we need to be able to generate
the interactive dialog flow right using
those questions uh and then lastly we
need to have a system that can enable
the non-technical parents or teachers to
uh utilize these uh generally result and
automatically deploy them as chatbot
that's why you saw the demo at the
beginning right so uh the data
collection data labeling process is um
is that important uh bridge to bridge
the human uh user study of identify the
domain knowledge into a language or
artifact that the machine Learning
Community can actually use we collect
the Gutenberg story books suitable for
preschool kids and then we recruited
educational experts to create both
questions and answers anchored to those
storybooks texts
the task was very simple so we asked
these other experts if they were about
to tell this story to uh three to six
year old kid what question would they
ask
in this data set it embedded this domain
knowledge for example the learning
science theory suggests that we need to
balance the following seven types of
question categories to maximize the
language learning outcome so we we
tailor our data sets to make sure that
our question answer label the question
answers can actually have all to cover
all these categories
we also compare our data set with the
existing QA and the narrative data like
narrative queue and other things uh that
you know to to show the unique
characteristics then we need to build a
benchmark models right and to to show
that there was the uh like you know the
off the shelf like uh part uh
Transformer models if you fine-tune it
down they stated how it will look like
to give the ml Community a Target so
that they can beat
after that no because no we want to uh
deliver a system to support these users
but there's a uh the existing that
Benchmark model was not good enough to
support that uh user scenario we decided
to design our own model architecture uh
to enhance the existing you know a
sequence of sequence model to support
our own uh use case
in comparison to the various other like
you know question answer pair generation
systems our model uh is the other two
baselines
here are some you know qualitative
results but I I think due to the time I
really need to be faster so back to the
bottom line right so this uh Bridge the
outcome the art the model artifact from
the Brazilian committee into the
targeted non-technical users uh real
world scenario the design here for
example we have this uh design that can
show the uh to emphasize the acceptable
AI feature that you know for any of
these equations we highlight where or
which sentence that the question is
being generated using a attention-based
you know explanation resolution right
also our goal or our purpose is for
human AI collaboration not to have AIS
is replaced so the parents or the
cheaters right so here what we are
really trying to do is to use the AI
model to help the parents and teachers
to come up with questions faster and
quicker but they can decide human can
decide whether to use these questions or
not if they don't want to use it they
can just you know remove all of them or
they can come up with their own ones by
you know editing and typing after
they're happy with that they click one
deploy button so one the case are
actually interacting with this system uh
you know themselves is a purely a speech
based interaction modality because these
are three to six years of all the kids
that they may not be able to actually
read
right then we conducted this
user study with 10 pair of uh touring
parents and this is the user study
setting during the code that's all you
can do right and our results shows that
uh people really love this direction so
this uh we then in the paper we also
discussed you know the various other
findings and the design implications
such as the role of AI in parent-child
interaction
uh
to quickly sum up right so in this
particular uh case study the second case
study uh we are demonstrating this full
cycle of closing the loop right where
you can work together with a
interdisciplinary research and engineer
team uh to uh start with the
understanding of a human knowledge to my
knowledge and then transfer them into a
task that machine Learning Community
really care about and then Translating
that emerging Community is artifact back
to support the actual user in the uh in
the Target scenario
let me very quickly go through the the
last one uh two minutes so in this last
one uh I was trying to demonstrate how
we can learn from human human
collaboration to guide the design of
human AI collaboration
the whole project was supported by
various user studies qualitative
research quantitative research to
understand how data science
collaborating a team then we draw this
uh data science life cycle starting from
the top that you define problem gather
data build model deploy model support
the decision right
using that a data science product
lifecycle we also map it uh up together
with the multiple stakeholders there are
more technical uh stakeholders there are
more uh business oriented stakeholders
right and then who's working with whom
along with which uh step in that life
cycle
after that we can then design this uh
IBM Auto AI product or no it's a product
so fundamentally behind the scene is a
auto ml system or set of technology that
can automatically select algorithms
select hyper parameters select the video
engineering Transformers
like a four five feature uh feature uh
uh engineering methods for the data
scientist so um uh one minute demo
to get started just upload your data
choose what you want to predict
then start your experiment
if you need to add multiple data sources
Auto AI provides optional
recommendations to guide you through the
process of joining your data for the
experiment
[Music]
once you run the experiment Auto AI
visualizes the model creation process
step by step each model is constructed
through a unique process which is called
a pipeline and a dynamic leaderboard
keeps track of the top ranking pipelines
throughout the experiment
Auto AI reduces the workload that used
to take days or weeks to a matter of
minutes you can interact with the
visualization at any time during the
model creation process to view different
lenses on the experiment through one
lens explore the unique or shared
relationships between each pipeline from
a top-down view through another lens
view the breakdown of each pipeline's
resulting metrics and from there you can
further refine these metrics to surface
the most relevant pipelines you can
instantly save each one in your
preferred format which can be
additionally tested or modified before
deployment
[Music]
okay so uh the whole like Auto ml
workflow as you can see in those colored
box each color box is a piece of code
right so in that color box it's trying
to map with the human data science
workflow right and then we design the
user interaction Point as if they are
exchanging this knowledge or requirement
or or artifacts with their human peers
that's how we built this uh Autos system
and then again we recruited uh data
science practitioners and I'll split
them into two teams and measure both
quantitative and qualitative results
from using Auto AI versus like using
turbine notebook to come up with their
code
um it's again very promising that is
that from using human from studying
human human collaboration uh theories
and Concepts and uh behaviors it can
guide us to say oh how to build this
successful user interaction and user
interface for humans under AI
uh
just no three future work uh democracy
AI from the work that you saw that these
are o o
from this all the work and the you know
sorry body work that we are trying to
enable non-technical user being able to
get benefit from uh this uh state of art
AI uh technology but without having them
to write the code so that's the
democratizing AI
um AI for AI democracy AI Vision
um also you know so far many of our work
have been focusing on AI to support one
individual user right but we believe
this AI for team and team for AI
scenario or just a research topic would
be more and more popular uh into the
future
uh lastly in this democratization AI
theme that you know we need to support
more Nitro interaction designs such as
this multimodality or cyber physical
systems right in such a way that you
know more like non-technic or other
people with low AI liters you can
actually interact with these AI systems
in a environment that they really care
about
uh
three more slice one uh what I'm
currently working on uh I'm currently at
work I'm I'm very interested in this uh
social bias uh kind of topic uh ethical
NLP topic right so from this historic uh
buddy project we annotated lots of
Gutenberg like storybooks these are Snow
White's you know Cinderella Alibaba and
fortices and then you can see uh there
are very clear social uh biases you know
or stereotypes in it like you know the
the male character is a doctor right
they travel abroad never short of money
and then try his luck save the princess
right the daughter of the king eater
Apple grown a pair of horns start crying
and then wait to be saved by the uh
Prince right so we want we have a
hypothesis that this is actually one of
the middle reasons why the social
stereotypes are passing out from one
generation to another generation uh
regarding this this uh uh culture
background because snow wise and the
Cinderella these are storybooks read by
you know millions of uh children like uh
across the globe if we can build a LP
toolkit that can automatically detect
this kind of like you know biases in the
narratives then we may be able to
develop a technology to help the
children book writers today to to give
them some guidance or you know a second
opinion uh when they are writing uh
these drafts right so we have a paper uh
just finish the draft and they put on
archive uh trying to assemble various uh
NRP tokens together to support it
um graph I'll skip that another big live
map work so this is the final one is
from the auto air project it was a very
nice demo and the other visualization
right but it was trying to use AI to
support the data scientists who already
know how to program AI it was not a very
easy cell uh let's do it that way so my
counter work is actually uh we're
shifting our Focus to focus on the
domain experts who have no skill in in
programming right and their current
nieces how can they translate their
massive existing data from the past
centuries all right so into a usable
data that can be used to train machine
models right and then uh this Human air
decision making I I formulate this data
annotation task as a humanity is making
so that once you have this AI system
right they can start to to eat with
themselves uh or or you know and also
make predictions suggestions so humans
tasks uh changed or shift shift from
consuming that message uh and to make
that decision themselves two uh whether
I agree with or disagree with the you
know the ai's selection uh along this
line right we built this as loose open
source product together with uh
Michael's research team as well as some
other universities and releases to the
open source Community we hope that you
know the community can enjoy this kind
of active learning enabled week
supervision data annotation system
uh also this same idea can be applied to
other scenarios like in Twitter right so
if you have a Twitter you have a
personalized model that we are training
this model while you are browsing it and
then we expose it to you so that you can
say oh this is a
inaccurate news this is accurate news
along with your interaction the model is
actually iterating itself and updating
is a prediction right how the people
interact with this kind of like
personalized AI model uh there's also
some like ongoing research project
uh once you have ai to the left and then
you have humor making this decision
right we know that there's over Reliance
under realigns all these kinds of like
interaction uh issues what if we provide
a second opinion from another human that
that talk calendar right so you're you
are the pendant there's a dog there's a
AI right
will you agree or disagree will that
help to reduce the overall line so when
you have a different opinion from your
human peers right these are also uh
interesting
research topics
the last one I want to uh tell you a
little bit more about you know again
data annotation but in this case I'm
feeling like this human in the loop AI
uh it's still missing the important
flavor it's because human Loop let's
think about it right the loop what was
the loop in the human in the loop right
it's the AI loop it's the AI algorithm
right so it's assuming that the AI
cannot perform something well so we need
human to help AI to improve ai's
performance that fundamentally is
against the humans Intuition or human
incentive uh model what if we switch it
to make it AI in the loop right so this
uh imagine that you know in this
particular AI in the loop process that
Loop is the human workflow right so we
study how humans are doing those work in
this case it's just you know annotating
the PDF it's writing table it's writing
image extracting text right but how are
people doing that right we decompose
that into those micro tasks and then
identify which particular task that
human need help and what AI can help in
that task from there we build this AI in
the loop process it actually have lots
of benefits for example a human doesn't
feel like their job are being replaced
or threatened by AI because they know
that their job is multi-stage like
end-to-end workflow but AI or different
AI can only help with a couple of them
that actually you know make this AI
system more acceptable and more helpful
for user
um with that I want to conclude my talk
thank you so much for coming to this
talk thanks
[Applause]
all right we have a few minutes for
questions I'll pass the mic around
thank you so much so I just wanted to
ask a question about the human AI
interfaces so throughout the talk you
showed a few interfaces um most of them
seem to be like text messaging sort of
things with chat Bots and there was also
this assistant especially with the rise
of generative AI I'm wondering what sort
of I mean like I feel like a text
messaging thread can only go so far in
in terms of like human AI interactions
so I'm wondering what sort of Novel
interface directions exist or that
you're exploring right now yes oh that
that's a very good uh observation uh you
know it's simply because my personal uh
like favorite the interaction away is
these graphically different interface as
well as the NATO language uh uh based
kind of interaction that's why most of
my research work of primary focus on the
NLP kind of Technology right so you've
done this but uh I also know uh some of
our uh collaborators are now uh moving
including myself we're moving into the
multi-modality scenario for example in
that storybook a product a next step is
that we know that these keys are being
coming more engaged if you can also
generate a sketch to show them together
with reading the storybook right so that
is the text to image or text to video
candidate generation capability but we
haven't find a very good model of the
shop model to support that we
our Benchmark in this make a video and a
model that recently released by Facebook
right but if we can add that to make
this a purely speech based interaction
to become more multimetology we are sure
that for this particular targeted
audience three to six years old kid
would be more engaging thank you thank
you
hello okay
um thank you for the talk I'm wondering
um
I think you said that you did not
disclose the identity of the AI to the
participants in the first study that you
showed us
um what did you say about it
uh what so we have a uh
just a user Persona user profile and
then we use that and then connect with
the API the systems API endpoint to
collect and post the messages back to
the community yeah so what was the user
persona the user Persona is uh just a
like regular user with having another
real face people's phaser and then
preparing to become uh like being
prepared to become pregnant something
okay so so that's um that's one type of
the user in that online community and
because you know our our research isn't
indeed falls into that category so she
used that user problem okay
um
yeah I was just wondering because I'm
like thinking about like prior work
where like
depending on who like what the name is
or like like how old the person is right
like that'll affect the way that people
interact with it
um so I'd be curious if like in the
future that could be like randomized in
some ways yeah like that would like yeah
well you know they're saying give me the
next step for that project because
whenever I give the talk many people are
so interested in this uh AI identity uh
research topic so the immediate next
step is actually try to you know have
this uh you know two group like a
control experiment to see if we review
the identity version how to reveal that
and see how the people feel about or you
know reveal that then say like oh this
is a condom on the reason right now the
not not not AI not the Community member
but rather a condom models are hired or
recruited by the platform maybe these
three different conditions uh people
will have different reaction yeah cool
thanks thank you
okay
I'll take the host prerogative you know
you started with talking about how the
you want to reconsider the
the user Center design process around
trying to bring AIS into this and I feel
like a cynical view of what you
presented would be to say
it's just user centered design yes where
AIS you know just like any other tool we
might use in our interaction design
toolkit yep
um
I feel like you probably have an opinion
that that's not exactly the case and I
want to give you a soapbox for a moment
and just say like what's what's
different here that you feel like if you
were going to be telling someone what do
I need to teach you beyond the sort of
user Center design process that we might
teach in an undergraduate Core
Curriculum what do you need to know if
you're building with AI in the loop yes
yeah oh thank you so much so that that's
the message I want to pass on so first
like you know two parts right of that
matter first user Center design all the
things that we are learning in today's
like HCI class or user uh Centric design
class right it's still valid so you
should you know still hold a belief in
it and don't try to play some like trick
or some Noble things to to say oh it's
expired already right so that's the
first of all the message that's why I
was saying like users and their design
AI is just another design material for
you right it was like you know a wipe
becoming available right in the past
decades and you just need to adapt to it
second part of that message is that
being
designed like background or student or
you know being an HCI student nowadays
in the school is actually a personal
opinion it's actually necessary and
critical to start to learn some AI
fundamentals right what's the
different categories of AI technology
out there was a limitation was the
benefit was the capability of these
different at home it's not just it's not
asking you to be able to write the code
and build your own model it's rather to
prepare you with that language with that
mindset so that you can collaborate with
your future engineer colleagues and
Reserve colleagues uh that's that's
That's essential because I'm observing
so many
failure products is because the
designer that we have in in literally
today most of them were trained
primarily using the the web base or
mobile phone like design they they feel
they have fear when they start to work
on AI driven products sometimes they
they over uh uh like uh estimated AI
capabilities sometimes so they just you
know try to step uh stay away from those
kind of products that's something that I
think you know we while you're still a
student you should you know get yourself
familiar with those and learn those
skills all right now let's take our
speaker one more time
thank you